[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti io mi chiamo emman
oldi ho 22 anni e scrivo
canzoni Ammetto che quando ho iniziato a
pensare a cosa avrei voluto dire qua
oggi mi sono fermata esattamente a
questa frase mi chiamo Eme ho 22 anni e
scrivo
canzoni non sapevo bene di cos'altro
parlare Non sapevo bene cos'altro dire
da dove vengo che cosa penso io in
merito a qualcosa che non sia la musica
perché Perché io io non ho il ruolo non
ho le competenze non ho l'esperienze
giuste per parlare di qualcosa che vada
oltre aarvi delle canzoni quindi ho
pensato che la cosa più funzionale fosse
partire dai risultati che ho ottenuto e
da lì dirvi come ho fatto ad ottenerli
Qual è stato il pensiero Qual è stato il
concetto l'idea la mia storia la cosa
che mi ha portato ad essere qua oggi qua
su questo palco a raggiungere gli
obiettivi a raggiungere i traguardi a
raggiungere il
successo però c'era un problema che io
non ho raggiunto proprio niente e io non
ho raggiunto niente che a me sembri così
straordinario da essere raccontato Qua
oggi niente che avrebbe un vero peso su
un curriculum non ho numeri a
supportarmi non ho classifiche a
supportarmi ho soltanto delle canzoni a
difendermi e quindi di cosa
parlarvi Quindi ho deciso che voglio
parlarvi esattamente di
questo voglio parlarvi dell'avere 22
anni e del non aver fatto ancora niente
di speciale e del fatto che questo sia
del tutto
normale grazie
Probabilmente fa strano che io dica
Questo qua Oggi fa strano un po' Anche a
me fa strano anche che voi mi stiate
applaudendo perché io abbia detto questa
cosa ma penso che ci sia un forte
bisogno di dirla e che questa cosa abbia
senso di essere detta io penso che Lucio
Dalla diceva in una canzone l'impresa
eccezionale da Miretta è essere normale
Ecco io Penso che le persone se la
debbano un po' ricordare questa cosa e
non per
appiattirsi nostri angoli ce la dovremmo
un po' ricordare per curarci per curarci
da questa ossessione di dover essere per
forza qualcuno o qualcosa prima del
nostro tempo di dover aver già capito
tutto quello che siamo e che vogliamo
essere a 22 anni quasi che se non si sa
a 22 anni sembra così
tardi Siamo circondati da Storie opposte
alla mia Siamo circondati da da storia
di di persone che ce l'hanno fatta da
chi è arrivato prima degli altri da chi
ha scoperto qualcosa prima degli altri e
questo sì Da una parte ci sprona da una
parte è qualcosa che ci carica ci
permette di provare sempre a fare di più
ma dall'altra è anche
qualcosa che ci fa sentire estremamente
ritardo Io penso che la mia generazione
e quelle successive alla mia questo
ritardo questa sensazione ce l'abbiano
tutti un po'
addosso penso che la mia generazione e
quelle successive la mia soffrano di una
pressione sociale che toglie il fiato ai
più determinati e la voglia ai meno
determinati Per chi è come me e
Credetemi io lo sento tanto questo
questa sensazione di essere sempre in
ritardo succede che a una certa ci
priviamo di guardarci intorno ci
fissiamo su una cosa e ci priviamo di
annoiarci di lasciare un po' di
vuoto si crea così una gerarchia delle
cose importanti Quando pensi che
raggiungere i tuoi obiettivi sia cosa
più importante che esista è come se
tutto il resto facesse da contorno ci
sono i tuoi obiettivi e poi c'è l'amore
l'amicizia tutto ciò che li contorna e
così pensi che l'amore la famiglia anche
l'amicizia siano meno sfuggenti meno
sfuggevoli meno sottoposte al passare
del tempo ma non è
così non è assolutamente così a me fa
talmente paura pensare di star perdere
tempo che quando succede che io mi
innamoro sia una cosa che Ricerco sia
una cosa che mi fa sentire viva che mi
fa scrivere canzoni ma è anche qualcosa
che mi fa paura mi fa paura che
addirittura mentre io mi innamoro stia
perdendo del tempo importante per fare
quello che adesso sembra più importante
e su questo ho scritto una
[Musica]
canzone
ho paura di incastrarti in ogni
[Musica]
giorno mentre incastriamo gli arti per
toccarci tutto allo stesso
momento gambe sopra gambe faccia a
faccia II nostri corpi speculari effetto
specchio è tutto troppo veloce Vorrei
andarmene ma ormai non ci
riesco vogliono insegnarci ad amare ma
abbiamo troppi impegni e poco tempo per
capirci vogliono insegnarci ad amare ma
poi quando ci proviamo preferiamo
addormentarci Cerco qualcuno che veda il
tempo da quando tu lo stai
rubando quando stiamo insieme perdo
tutte le mie
forze Cerco qualcuno che venda il
tempo quando tu lo stai
rubando ai tuoi occhi Io mi arrendo cedo
le mie
Forse un giorno dura troppo poco dirti
ciò che penso o forse a me che non
riesce bene ma tu leggi nella mente è
questa cosa che D stabilizza confondo
pace con insicurezza Sei tutto quello
che mi rallenta abito dentro a chi mi
frequenta stessa frequenza muovi la mia
culla addormenta nulla linea sveglia
interna Se mi allontano è perché mi
spaventi impegnata e impegnativa
creatura È creativa riflessa riflessiva
troppo veloce ma poco viva incontrarti
per questo serviva a sganciarmi dal Temp
Temp a scordarmi di quel
tempo che gli altri ci impongono e con
te sto esaurendo Cerco qualcuno che veda
il tempo da quando tu lo stai
rubando quando stiamo insieme al aperto
tutte le mie
forze Cerco qualcuno che veda il tempo
da quando tu lo stai
trando ai tuoi occhi Io mi arrendo cedo
le mie
[Musica]
[Applauso]
forze
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quindi sì mi fa molta paura perdere
tempo mi fa molto P perdere tempo ma
sono anche convinta di una cosa sia
razionalmente che emotivamente io sono
convinta che esista un vuoto utile un
vuoto utile a far spazio a nuove cose da
conservare un un vuoto utile a trovare
nuove cose da conservare sono convinta
che esistano delle cose inutili utili a
scoprire cose di noi stessi oggi
sembrano un po' tutti avere la risposta
esatta con titoli tipo 10 semplici passi
per scoprire chi sei gestisci bene il
tuo tempo e il mondo sarà tuo come
realizzarti nella vita e poi la skincare
la mor in R la palestra cosa mangiare
quando mangiarlo e l'ap del sonno quando
dormire Quanto dormire si parla
tantissimo di essere performanti per
raggiungere i nostri obiettivi e
pochissimo di essere sereni e
consapevoli per capire quali
effettivamente siano i nostri
obiettivi
Grazie sia a tutti un grandissimo
desiderio di far vedere le nostre
conoscenze e non proprio un puro
desiderio di
conoscere sono secondo me tutti
tentativi Goffi per cercare un ordine
delle risposte esatte a delle domande
che delle risposte esatte purtroppo non
ce le avranno mai non esisterà mai
un'equazione per capire cosa davvero
succederà Io penso che si parta per
suggerire un modo per affrontare il
vuoto e i momenti di perdizione e si
finisca però a volte per suggerire un
modo per effettivamente smettere di
chiedersi Come si sta per smettere di
pensare ci si di impegni e quando c'è il
giorno vuoto Non sappiamo più cosa fare
Non sappiamo più chi siamo senza quegli
impegni non sappiamo più
definirci ci si dimentica di quanto
quelle sensazioni fastidiose quella
stessa noia quello stesso tedio quella
scomodità siano Sì fastidiose ma
estremamente utili da sentire davvero
per capire chi siamo Io sono sempre
stata convinta di avere tutto in mano
che solo e soltanto le mie azioni
determiner il futuro un fantomatico
futuro Ide Che sto inseguendo scrivendo
liste quotidiane di cose da fare e
purtroppo non è così le nostre azioni
non determinano il futuro non sono
quelle che assolutamente determinano il
nostro futuro ma sicuramente determinano
cò ciò che siamo adesso e se tutto ciò
che facciamo è seguire queste linee
guida è seguire le regole è seguire
quello che ci sembra giusto tutto ciò
che stiamo faccendo è costruire dei
paletti dentro i quali stare costruendo
il nostro personalissimo recinto che è
un luogo sicuro ma dove non entrano
davvero le
ispirazioni io ho deciso di voler essere
un po' più delle regole più del giusto
più di una lista di cose da fare ho
deciso di voler essere una grandissima
quantità di sbagli di facce incontrate
di tempo perso e ritrovato nei ricordi
perché penso che siano proprio queste le
cose che sembrano vuote che un giorno ci
riempiranno
Gabriel Garcia diceva la vita non è
quella che si è vissuta è quella che si
ricorda e Come la si ricorda Ecco io
oggi non vi posso dire cosa ho fatto di
importante ma vi posso dire cosa farò
che a me sembra importante Io voglio
guardare in faccia la mia piccolezza
Voglio guardare in faccia il mio essere
normale il mio essere una tra milioni e
fare di questa piccolezza un'opportunità
per sentirmi ancora più libera una
poetessa di nome Maria Angela Gualtieri
inizia una poesia dicendo sommamente
urgente è questo silenzio che viene Ecco
a chi come me Lancia in testa i pensieri
II come un giocoliere lanciare a birilli
dico concediti un po' di silenzio
concediti un po' di vuoto dormi
concediti un po' di pace e ritrova la
forza per sbagliare ancora Grazie
mille
somamente somamente urgente è questo
silenzio che viene quindi ora per non
dare retta neanche a me vi sono l'ultima
canzone Grazie
[Musica]
mille Non
vedo l'ora
di sapere tutto di
te Non
vedo l'ora di portarti dove mi
perdo
che cosa mi hai
aperto com'è che adesso sento qualcosa
[Applauso]
[Musica]
passare cosa mi hai
fatto per la prima volta mi son potuta
calmare ho sempre avuto fretta sempre
finto di avere pazienza e ancora una
volta ho scelto il momento
sbagliato È sempre il momento
sbagliato
dormi non ne vale la pena di restare
svegli ci alziamo tra qualche
anno quando avranno smesso
di metterti
[Musica]
paura passerà il tempo senza che tu te
ne
accorga provare a cambiare il mondo è
una lotta apersa e io non vorrei mai che
tu ti sentissi
sconfitta Non
vedo l'ora di portarti al
[Musica]
buio raccontarti i
segreti quelli che non dico alla gente
purché ci sia sempre un
limite non vedo l'ora di
di poterti
svegliare dirti è tutto
finito possiamo tornare a
nasconderci ma questa volta a
nasconderci
[Musica]
[Applauso]
insieme Ho sempre avuto fretta ma tu
meriti la mia
pazienza ancora una volta in questo
momento sbaglia
è sempre il momento
sbagliato
[Musica]
dormi non ne vale la pena di restare
svegli ci alziamo tra qualche
anno quando avranno smesso di metterti
[Musica]
paura
dmi passerà il tempo senza che tu te ne
accorga provare a cambiare il mondo è
una lotta persa e io non vorrei mai che
tu ti sentissi
sconfitta
[Musica]
dormi
h
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie
[Applauso]
mille